CREATIVITY: IT’S AT THE HEART OF WHO WE
HUMANS ARE…
…WITH BRAINS EQUIPPED BY EVOLUTION TO INVENT,
TO WRITE, TO MAKE ART AND MUSIC.
WE HUMANS ARE SPECIAL, RIGHT?
BUT WAIT.
WHAT IF A ROBOT COULD PAINT A MASTERPIECE?
WHAT IF ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE COULD COMPOSE
GREAT MUSIC?
DOES A ROBOT – A MACHINE WITH ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE – DRIVEN BY CODE AND ALGORITHMS
-- FEEL AND EXPRESS ITSELF UNIQUELY AND ORIGINALLY?
You’re just a machine, an imitation of life.
Can a robot write a symphony?
Can a robot turn a canvas into a beautiful
masterpiece?
Can you?
OVER SOME 40,000 YEARS, HUMAN CREATIVITY HAS
EXPLODED – FROM DRAWINGS ON CAVE WALLS THROUGH
THE GREAT ART OF CENTURIES TO COME….
TO EVER MORE ADVANCED TECHNOLOGY AND DESIGN.
NOW, SCIENTISTS -- AND ARTISTS --ARE ASKING
CAN A ROBOT TRULY IMAGINE AN ORIGINAL MASTERWORK?
OR CAN IT ONLY COPY THE PATTERNS OF A HUMAN
PAINTER…
OR MUSICIAN?
DOES THIS COMPUTER VERSION OF VIVALDI SOUND
LIKE THE REAL THING?
CAN ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE FEEL EMOTION AND
TURN IT INTO ART?
DO ALGORITHMS WITH YES-NO OPTIONS HAVE THE
POTENTIAL FOR UNLIMITED CREATIVITY?
EVEN THE HUMAN BRAIN, WITH ITS 86 BILLION
NEURONS, MAY HAVE CREATIVE LIMITS.
COMPUTATIONAL CREATIVITY IS LEADING US TO
ASK NEW QUESTIONS ABOUT HUMAN CREATIVITY.
IS THIS ESSENTIAL HUMAN TRAIT TRULY UNIQUE?
HOW FAR CAN IT TAKE US?
WILL ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE BE A COMPETITOR?
OR CAN IT BE A COLLABORATOR, HELPING US TOWARD
STILL UNIMAGINED CREATIONS?
Hello and welcome to Computational Creativity.
My first guest is a member of Google Brain’s
Magenta team.
He is currently working on neural network
models of sound and music and recently produced
a synthesizer that designed its own sounds.
He’s also a jazz guitarist.
Please welcome Jesse Engel.
Also with us, is an Assistant professor at
the University of Illinois at Urbana Champaign
in the Dept. of Electrical and Computer Engineering.
He focuses on several surprising creative
domains including the culinary arts and fashion
and the theoretical foundations of creativity.
Please welcome Lav Varshney
Also with us is an Associate Professor of
psychological and brain science at Dartmouth
College.
He’s interested in the neural basis of imagination
and in the evolution of human creativity.
Please welcome Peter Tse.
And finally, an artist in residence at Bell
Labs exploring new forms of drawing with virtual
reality, biometrics, machines learning and
robotics.
A former research fellow at MIT’s Media
lab and artist in residence at Google, please
welcome Sougwen Chung.
Peter, it seems like there are many possible
pros and cons for approaching computational
creativity.
One potential con would be we don’t even
fully understand human creativity yet.
As someone who has studied the evolution of
human creativity, where does it come from,
what do we know about it, what don’t we
know about it?
So we’re mammals that have descended from
a very long lineage and in the hominin lineage,
we diverged from chimpanzees something like
seven million years ago, from the common ancestors
with chimpanzees and bonobos about seven million
years ago.
And we went through a long period of having
small brains, we were bipedal, the australopithecines
which you can see in the lower left there
and the lower middle.
But then around 2.2 million years ago, homo
habilis created stone tools and these Olduvai
stone tools were very simple, basically just
broken rocks.
But then about 1.8 million, 2.0 million years
ago, homo erectus in the upper middle there
created a kind of hand axe called the Acheulean
hand axe which hardly changed for a million
and a half years.
So it’s really striking is how un-innovative
homo erectus was…
Had one idea and stuck with it.
And then heidelbergensis, which is in the
upper right there is about six hundred to
eight hundred thousand years ago.
Again, very non innovative and even the Neanderthals
who had the so-called Mousterian tool set,
it hardly changed for over one hundred fifty
thousand years.
And then our species shows up, and in the
case of Europe kind of in the middle of Europe
probably came up the Danube and couldn’t
go any further and their artifacts are incredible,
you see the first evidence of instruments,
of art and we can know for sure how this came
about because thoughts don’t leave fossils,
neuro-circuits don’t leave fossils, all
we have are bones and skulls and artifacts.
But the artifacts that show up are just incredible;
stone flutes…
I mean bone flutes and beautiful art.
So something happened in our neural circuitry
that afforded us the capacity to think of
such things and then paint them or create
them.
And some of them involve the creation of objects
that existed in their world like that bison
up there, but some of them involve the creation
of objects that could not exist.
And near Un in what is now Germany, there’s
a cave where they found this Löwenmensch,
this lion headed human.
So there was never a lion headed human, somebody
had to imagine that, thirty-five to forty
thousand years ago and then go and build it.
I’m very interested in the neural circuitry
that could have created that.
Just to be clear, this is not a result of
some kind of physical evolution, the brain
pan doesn’t get… we don’t see an increase
in the size of the brain in the species.
No we do see an increase in the size of the
brain from roughly the size of a chimpanzee,
three hundred fifty cubic centimeters, up
through homo habilis getting up to maybe six
hundred CC, homo erectus gets bigger and bigger
and the Neanderthals actually had brains that
were bigger than ours, much bigger, well not
much bigger maybe fourteen hundred, fourteen-fifty
CC whereas ours is in the thirteen hundreds.
And yet Neanderthals with their bigger brains
were not very innovative, their tools hardly
changed.
But what really seems to change in our skulls
and in our brains, because the skull molds
to fit the brain… is this, our foreheads
got really big.
So something about our frontal cortex changed
and I suspect this is central to our becoming
more creative.
So when did this happen, I mean homo sapiens
as a species was around for a while and it
seems like what you’re saying, it sort of
describes a J curve where there’s a sudden
explosion of…
It’s a big puzzle right, so I can look at
a skull from one hundred-thirty thousand years
ago and it looks more or less like a modern
skull.
But the first evidence of sort of jewelry
and art is maybe seventy, maybe eighty-thousand
years ago in South Africa in the Blombos Cave.
And in Europe, Cro-Magnon man our species
shows up about forty-one thousand years ago
give or take a couple thousand of years.
And it really seemed to be a big bang, a cultural
big bang.
And what that was, I think nobody knows.
Was it a change in culture, a change in language?
Nobody knows.
Lav you’ve studied some of the theoretical
foundations of creativity.
It is important to at least ask these questions.
Because if we’re going to talk about computational
creativity, we need to know what we’re starting
from.
Exactly, and so what I’ve been working on
is a mathematical theory of creativity which
again seems perhaps strange, how can you mathematize
something like creativity?
And the way I’ve been defining it is, we
want things that are both novel as well as
high quality in the domain.
So if we’re thinking about food, we want
it to be flavorful or if we want fashion,
we want it to be visually appealing perhaps.
But novelty seems to be fairly consistent
across domains.
Things that change your beliefs are perhaps
the most surprising and the most novel.
The human brain as neuroscientist know, has
balanced the need for knowing what’s coming
next, expectation, the satisfaction the brain
gets when it knows the next digit in the sequence
or the next word in the sentence versus novelty.
Whether you can mathematically determine that
sweet spot is still kind of an open question
I would imagine.
It is, yeah.
How to balance novelty against familiarity
that’s really the question that artists
face.
You don’t want to deviate too much perhaps
because then its not understandable but you
definitely want to push the envelope.
So with food, does the computer put together
things that no human chef would ever dream
of putting together, like blueberries and
pork?
Yeah, you can definitely come up with novel
combinations that have never been done before
so things like cocoa powder and saffron and
almonds for example, that’s incredibly good
Now…you’ve also been working with an algorithm
that...if we’re going to talk about artificial
intelligence learning.
There are the different algorithms and before
we get to Jesse and his musical tools.
Talk us through this algorithm that helps
learn a machine to learn to create music.
Right so what we wanted to do was essentially
learn what are the laws of music theory?
What are the principles of good music as it
were?
So what this algorithm is doing is it has
two parts.
Essentially a teacher that knows Bach and
a student who is trying to learn what is music.
And they iterate between each other
So we want to build this hierarchy of concepts
in music, and further we want them to be human
interruptible.
So that’s roughly what this algorithm tries
to do and then eventually, we can use those
principles then to inform composition and
the generative question of creativity.
So is there an analogy to how we as humans
would learn the theory of making music?
Yeah in fact the rules that the algorithm
generates are exactly or nearly the ones that
are taught in music theory courses.
They go step by step in roughly the same way
though there are a couple of rules that come
out that some of our colleagues and colleagues
of music find kind of interesting as well,
things that they hadn’t noticed.
Now Jesse in the field of music we have seen
some attempts made a quote unquote generated
music.
Brian Eno for example in England has been
pursuing this for years.
What’s the attraction in taking something
so inherently human and trying to expand that
into the world of artificial intelligence?
That’s a great question.
So I think it’s interesting to think of
things in the context that creativity and
tools have always been co-involving.
We weren’t able to… you know the evolution
of well tempered instruments allowed for playing
in multiple keys, algorithm and machine learning,
artificial intelligence are just sort of the
next step in this process where they’re
creating new opportunities to interact with
composition, new ways to interact with sonic
texture and just new tools to express ourselves
creatively.
What are you and the Magenta team at Google,
what is your kind of approach to the music
creativity process?
What’s interesting about machine learning
and what’s called AI is that it’s really
a data driven way or at least a lot of the
current methods are a data driven way of discovering
some of these core components to a given set
of data, whether it be audio from someone
talking or the core components of a recipe
or anything like that.
And so once you’ve identified these core
components, then you can start playing games
about how can I mix and match them?
The systems aren’t perfect, they fail in
interesting ways because they’re trying
to do the best they can, and they’re trying
to do it according to the data we show them
and the data that we show them comes from
the natural world.
So the mistakes they make are somewhat in
line with the natural world.
And so they have a kind of more humanistic
character to them.
Which is actually a great source of, it’s
a different kind of creativity.
This is creativity through trial and error
you know, or mistakes.
Well that sounds very human.
Jamaican musicians in the early 60’s listening
to offshore radio from the southern American
states and thinking I’ve got to do me some
of that R&B stuff and getting it wrong and
creating reggae.
This is how almost every kind of development
in our arts has happened.
Or like in the case of, that the 808 drum
machine was originally invented to be a perfectly
accurate drummer, it was supposed to be a
replacement of a drummer.
But it wasn’t, it sounds like a drum in
a box.
But it actually the way that it was not perfect
with the kick drum and stuff was actually
the starting point for a lot of electronic
music and hip-hop.
So there’s the way that you have your creative
intention and it goes a little bit off but
if you’re guiding your creative intention,
if it’s grounded in the world, it can be
a great creative source as well.
With these machines, is the learning experiential,
can it be experiential?
Or is it completely based on what we the people
have taught it?
I definitely think it can be experiential,
the standard way of teaching things is to
give it a bunch of exemplars, and then it
has to try to… it meaning the algorithm
that you come up with has to try to determine
some structure within that.
But there’s an alternative way where you
give a bunch of core components and an algorithm
can try to combine these components in different
ways.
Evolutionary algorithms where you sort of
take these two things and you say what if
I combine them, I would have a child of them.
There’s also reinforcement learning where
you sort of give it feedback if it combines
two things in a good way, then you say okay
good job and it does more things like that.
And those are some of the frontiers of these
types of algorithms.
At the table there you have a kind of melody
generating system that puts this theory into
practice right?
Right, so the Google Magenta project is part
of a machine learning research group.
So we do fundamental research, but one of
the key things I think often gets overlooked
is there’s always a human in the creative
process.
So it’s an open source project that we try
to get as much engagement from creative coders
and artist in the community.
And we try to create tools that allow these
artists to interact with these algorithms
without having to do a bunch of programing
on the command line and that type of stuff.
And so I just brought along a few of them
here to show.
Why don’t you demonstrate what one of these
can do?
Sougwen, while Jesse’s walking over to the
table, does this sound analogous to your sort
of collaboration?
I started a robotic drawing collaboration
a few years ago with the intent of exploring
how we can measure creativity and actually
reflects that back as a type of performance.
So I think as I come to work with the robotic
arm and with these new machine-learning algorithms,
I’ve come to view it as more of a collaborator
because of its ability to reflect our own
creative processes.
And I think that’s a new process that’s
only going to grow more in the future.
Now what are we looking at here?
So this is my project Drawing Operations Unit
Generation One.
It’s sort of a first very initial foray
into what it would be like to collaborate
with a robotic agent.
The first generation is really simple, I wanted
to show a few things, I wanted to show sort
of a human hand and a robotic arm working
in harmony cause I feel like that image is
really, and that narrative is underserved
in our culture now and also think about how
relationally and behaviorally the sort of
two organic and robotic units can work together
to create something beautiful or not and kind
of explore that side of ambiguity.
And Jesse was talking about, I think you were
saying that for you getting the feedback from
the machine affects your creative process,
so it becomes a feedback loop.
Absolutely.
You did bring one other video for us to watch.
What’s happening here?
Oh this is just sort of an older installation
work of mine.
I think it hits upon this sort of unique point
in history that we’re in.
Where a lot of how we work with traditional
mediums and how we engage in music and food
how that’s being shifted and transmuted
by these different technological systems.
So this is an installation project that I
did a few years ago combines sort of hand
made paper craft with computational graphics
to create an environment that’s sort of
this union of both.
So it is a genuine collaborative process?
It’s a hybrid process.
Let’s take a look.
So the idea that it’s a hybrid process it
seemed like maybe you were hedging on whether
it was a genuine collaboration yet, is that
the goal?
I think definitely that’s the goal for me.
I’d like to see more people engaged with
you know machine learning, behaviors as part
of a process they adopt into their own work.
I think we’re always inching closer and
closer toward true collaboration even with
human actors.
So there’s a real area to be explored there.
So what do you got over there?
Okay.
So what I have here is a demonstration a very
common type of model in machine learning,
where there’s-given a series of notes, it
looks for structure within those notes and
tries to keep on continuing and predicting
what would I play next if I was the one who
had played those notes.
And so there’s a lot of different ways you
can use that within a creative process and
so we’ve taken tens of thousands of popular
songs and just the notes from the songs, its
called midi data, but we train these models
to find the structure there and then to be
able to generate new sounds when conditioned
on-when listening to what it is someone is
playing.
So if sound works out here… just to keep
me at all centered I’m going to put a metronome
on… but I can do something where I might
have a melody that I’m going to play into,
and you’ll hear the electric piano, will
be me, then I’m going to hear a response
from the algorithm running on my computer
here that will be trying to continue what
I am playing, it will be a cello… might
go something simple
It might respond
So there’s some continuity there with what
I played before.
I have it looping actually, so you can hear
the response over and over again.
And you can hear some similarities of what
I played, but its not doing the job of trying
to replicate what I play, it’s trying to
continue it in a meaningful way.
It’s done a little inversion of some of
the…
… yea a little inversion, but you see it’s
sort of keeping to the same key and stuff
so if I then wanted to go and play chords
behind it and sort of say that sounds real
good as like a melody for my song maybe I
can build off that and be like…
… … something like that and all of a sudden
I have the start of course a very popular
hit song.
But that’s just sort of one type of way
that you can be using these tools.
and another type of way is the sounds themselves
right?
We know which instruments sounds like because
we made all of them.
But there are potentially a gazillion other
sounds out there.
So we have to take a whole bunch of individual
instruments and we have it learn the structure
between all those different instruments and
then provide that as a tool to a musician
so that you can interpolate between different
instruments and create sounds that are sort
of novel and new.
And yes, so it’s sort of a similar idea
but applied now to tambour and texture.
So like in this example, we can take the sound
originally of a flute.
Sounds like a flute.
Here’s the model’s best attempts to replicate
that sound.
And you notice it sounds more or less like
a flute but it messes up in some ways that
there’s this upper high frequency content
stuff.
But its actually like I was saying those are
the kind of mistakes we enjoy.
Its sort of like you’re running back in
the old days the 60’s people would run,
turn up their tune amplifiers and get this
upper harmonic distortion.
And so it’s sort of a natural type of distortion.
But you can take on the other side for novelty
sake let’s take a cat.
My wife loves cats so she was like you have
to do a cat… so here’s the model, it was
only trained on instruments like guitars and
flutes, this is it’s best attempts to recreate
a cat.
You know it sort of sounds like a cat, but
it’s like if the cat was played by something
else.
So if you take the flute and the cat and you
were just to add the numbers corresponding
to those waves together it would just sound
like the cat and the flute in the same room.
You know, there’s two separate sound sources
but instead, if we take those core components
that the network learns and we mix those core
components together then we get something
that is a new sound that combines elements
of the two sounds together.
So it sort of sounds like a flute that meows.
And I can then turn that into an instrument,
that I can play and of course it’s very
fun in novelty.
But we also want to encourage more that just
novelty, you know the creation of new... not
serious but personal expression.
So we’ve also created these tools and integrated
them into modern musical work flows as well.
Lav is there anything similar to that in…
Yeah so once you have these components you
can start playing around with them even in
other domains say like culinary.
You can say I want Asian flavored ceviche
using dairy products, so then you’ll have
an algorithm that’ll generate something
pretty flavorful and pretty good.
So you can set up… and I think this is probably
true for you Jesse as well, once you start
using these things you kind of get a sense
for what input parameters are good as well
so you learn how the tool works and you can
make it do better things.
And I think actually building the computational
creativity system gives you some insight into
that.
A great example is this was build with a data
set that we created and released to the open
public, was built off sample libraries and
the data set was really biased to trumpets,
synthesizers and stuff.
So it does, it sort of makes, like when I
play a piano through it, it doesn’t get
it just right and it kind of makes it sound
more like a trumpet.
And so there’s this even in the training
of a model, there’s creative inputs in the
terms of what is the data that you want it
to represent in these types of things.
So Sougwen let’s talk about the visual arts,
there has to be an analogy to be made there.
Well yeah, I was actually thinking about what’s
fascinating about Lav and Jesse’s work and
I think it’s that it takes place in the
site of ambiguity.
Like we know that when we train these sort
of new models of thinking to do things that
we already understand it’s kind of boring,
but when it’s to invent a new recipe or
if it’s to invent a new sound it becomes
a lot more compelling.
You found the cat/flute compelling?
I mean well that’s the thing it’s ambiguous
and it’s novel but I think there are ways
to create our own new narratives using these
tools.
Like instead of a cat and flute, I can have
a recording of my father’s voice and my
favorite song, the melody.
So suddenly I can hybridize those things it
becomes a very meaningful way of engaging
with each other and like the historical past.
I think while there’s a lot of novelty…
like I like a cat/flute, I’d love to play
a cat/flute.
I knew you did.
But there’s so many different ways we can
use these core components to create beautiful,
new interpretations that helps us understand
these sort of aspects of our histories a little
more.
Is there a way that these machines, this kind
of access that creativity has to those ambiguous
places, is that something you’re all working
towards?
If we develop these tools farther, if you
can treat it more like a garden, you know
rather than painting like the individual strokes
on a canvas where you’re controlling it
in the sense that you put a certain amount
of water on a plant, you choose what you plant
and how much fertilizer to give it or maybe
you’re really compulsive and you do like
bonsai, you know the cutting of all the leaves
and stuff.
But your control is more high level, and part
of the interesting part is letting the system
do whatever it is that it’s going to do.
And you understand the system, you go out
each day to your garden and you interact with
it as the things grow.
So I sort of think of AI gardens in that same
sense.
There’s various elements that you want control
over and there’s various elements that you
don’t.
And another thing that these computational
creativity algorithms give you is a sense
of safety in a way.
So you can explore parts of the creative space
that you might be afraid of a little bit,
because you have this kind of algorithm that’ll
guarantee that it’ll work out.
It’s a little bit like GPS, it allows you
to explore parts of the physical world and
you know you can get home.
So that’s another thing that really helps
me when I use these creative technologies,
pushes me a little outside my normal boxes
and puts me in different boxes but they’re
kind of somewhere else and I know it’ll
work out.
Actually I have a remark about that.
I feel the exact opposite about that.
As I think about collaborating with in a very
performative way, this robotic arm whether
it’s trained on my own style which Generation
Two is.
Or it’s just sort of mimicking my movements.
There’s a real randomness and sort of sense
of unpredictability to it, and lack of understanding
involved that it’s kind of exhilarating
and exciting but it is not safe, it doesn’t
feel safe or comforting at all, it’s like
staring into the void.
Well you know even among humans, the phenomenon
of apophenia where you have two dispirit,
unrelated bits of stimulus, the brain will
try to make some connections where maybe there
was no intention to begin with.
But a lot of artists Peter, make a lot of
hay with that.
Sure, and central to our kind of creativity
is taking known components and constructing
new things from them.
So I can say to you for example: imagine an
egg with wings that’s flying
around the statue of liberty holding an ice
cream cone instead of a torch.
And you can do that.
I could’ve just said anything.
And so these mental operations seem to take
place in this aspect of our consciousness
that is this internal virtual reality that
we may call imagination.
So consciousness has this sort of duo role,
telling us about the world and our bodies
in it but also this internal virtual reality.
And this is really central to what we do and
in order to that I think we have to have experience
in the real world with real things.
Actually, you know, in some of my work, we’ve
looked at the mental operations, for example,
rotating a physical object this way or this
way.
And then we can decode if someone’s imagining
rotating it this way or this way.
Probably because some similar brain circuits
are involved in actually imagining it in your
internal virtual reality, which you learned
in the real world.
There’s a program in France actually Sony
France, maybe Jesse you’ve heard this where
they fed every Beatles song into this computer
so that the computer could learn how the Beatles
wrote their songs.
And then they asked the computer to generate
its own Beatles like songs and you know, they
had human lyricists.
If
you grew up on the Beatles it’s just like
“eh, alright, that’s kind of cute.”
If you didn’t grow up on the Beatles though,
I don’t know what your response might, might
be something like, “oh my gosh, I’ve never
hear anything like this.
This is brilliant.”
So the idea… you’re absolutely right it
takes a conscious receptor to decide whether
something… and so this gets us into the
whole question of aesthetics and taste, whether
something is in fact creative or not.
Whether something is creative in the good
sense is going to be a human consciousness
that says, “oh, that taste good actually.”
And if my algorithm says well this should
taste good and I just, actually no, it comes
down to my conscious experience.
And computers at least the currently configured
are not conscious.
Our creativity is very much rooted in our
own conscious experience of a world and so
based on my own conscious experience of the
world, I form mental models, so I know what
it is for you to feel pain because I’ve
felt pain.
And we’re constantly modeling things that
are actually not in the input.
I’m modeling what’s going on in your mind,
based on what’s going on in my mind, that’s
not visible.
And so a lot of our creativity is rooted in
our mental models which in return is rooted
in our consciousness and so I’ll voice a
note of skepticism because in the absence
of mental models that are rooted in conscious
experience, robots and AI systems I think
will at best approach as if creativity.
I actually think that’s one realm in which
the arena of competitive games gets a lot
of traction in machine learning, is because
there is a set of constraints, there is a
winner and loser and styles.
So in that way, it creates a platform around
discussion that’s a little bit…
it’s more stable than a conversation about
aesthetics.
Do you feel like the realm of competitive
games and creating these models that could
be conscious, do you think that’s the right
approach?
Well when IBM created Deep Blue it could beat
Kasparov.
But it was doing a brute force search through
zillions of possibilities.
Whereas Kasparov would instantly see a pattern
so our brain is doing something very different
and it could beat him, just like an airplane
can fly faster than a bird but it’s doing
something very different from a bird, in this
case the human brain.
Well I want to take the, just for fun, the
contrary point of view on this because, so
a lot like you would use the Kasparov example
right, and there’s recently been these great
successes of this AlphaGo Program beating
the world champions in Go, and the way that
they do it is not through brute force search
because that’s, it’s just computational
intractable because the game of Go is much
more complex.
But they do it through the creation of these
functions to represent sort of intuition,
you know to represent like roughly how good
do I feel this move is, and I can’t tell
you exactly why I feel this good, but I have
this function that I’ve been learning that
says if these pieces are here and these pieces
are here, then moving here is a good move.
And it’s because I played a whole bunch
of games and I usually win when I put my piece
here and all those pieces are in those places.
And similarly, a lot of the really cutting
edge machine learning and reinforcement learning
algorithms explicitly have modeling of…
you know there’s some numbers present that
are saying okay this is my representation
of the environment around me.
This is my representation of what this other
actor is doing; this is a representation of
what of what I am doing as an actor in the
system.
So the concept that our creative critique
or, you know analysis is somehow a fundamentally
a human thing that requires consciousness.
I just find it to be a little bit of a small
definition because here you have, you can,
it’s very easy to imagine agents that can
do things similar in nature to what we might
consider to be consciousness, but it’s not
human consciousness.
It’s just sort of a broader definition on
how a thing interacts with its environment.
So you can have a computer critic and computer
artist that make art that’s optimized for
what a computer likes, but it’s not necessarily
optimized for what we want.
It doesn’t, just because it’s a possibility
doesn’t mean, I mean I think we’re always
going to lend toward creating systems that
you know we enjoy interacting with, that benefit
us as a society and benefit us in our own
expression.
Does it seem like there are limits, Peter
you should weigh in as well, to human creativity
and is there a limit to what artificial creativity
might be?
Yeah, so you can figure out what’s the maximum
speed a bird can fly through a forest without
crashing.
So right now the bird is going pretty slow
he can navigate sufficiently quickly and avoid
all the obstacles and then land on the tree.
But if he tries to go too fast he’ll crash
into the tree which is what I think happens
in the video.
And that’s exactly the fundamental speed
limit of a flight through forest.
And there’s a similar fundamental speed
limit for communication, and what we’ve
been trying to find and what we seem to be
finding is there’s a fundamental speed limit
to creativity as well.
There’s a fundamental tension, you can’t
be too novel in a given domain and you can’t
be too high quality in a domain.
There’s a tension between the two.
So it’s easy to be very novel and low quality
just put random stuff together.
It’s very easy to be high quality and low
novelty just look it up in your favorite cookbook
or wherever it is.
But doing both simultaneously is very difficult
and that’s where the limit is.
And the larger the inspiration set, the known
stuff, the harder it is to be creative.
So if there are people in the audience who
want to be creative, you should start a new
field where there’s much more low hanging
fruit actually.
Are there limits do you think to human creativity
as Lav was suggesting there are to computational
creativity?
I don’t know, I mean humans have proven
to be incredibly creative both in the good
sense of making airplanes for flight or for
murder.
I think of our human imagination as the greatest
tool and also the greatest weapon we have
because we can imagine the most amazing things
and also the most horrible things.
Like the holocaust, that was an act of imagination
actually.
And my hope is that these tools will eventually
foster human flourishing and not be used to,
you know also create new ways of murdering
people.
And I think one question that I would have
for everybody is; what is the goal of all
this?
Is it just simply to make new artifacts or
is it…
I mean when I was a kid there was the Jetsons
and they had this robot and you would say
“robot do the dishes.”
And it would do the dishes.
But is it to make a general-purpose intelligence
that would effectively be a slave?
My guess is in order to make a general-purpose
robot like the Jetsons robot, it would have
to be conscious so it would understand what
I mean when I say change the tires.
I have to have a whole model of a cars and
everything.
But if it’s conscious, then we have the
problem of slavery again because it would
suffer.
So consciousness implies self-awareness, awareness
of self as suppose to another or others.
The having of experience like pain, like seeing.
Could a robot be conscious without feeling
pain?
I suppose I mean there are actually humans
that don’t feel pain and they can see so
yeah.
Sociopaths…
Emotional pain, yeah.
Jesse what about at your end of things?
Yeah, I mean I think maybe another way of
thinking about it rather than just… it’s
like it’s really nice to reflect it back
on our own human experience.
As we’ve developed tools to better control
mechanical systems, we really began to better
understand how our bodies work.
But what’s amazing about these new systems
is they do a math that’s not human but it’s
similar in a way that can help us provide
introspections in terms of what are my mental
processes?
When I’m being self critical, what are the
dynamics of that, how can I interrupt that
process?
And how does that affect my creative output?
You can get introspection in a quantitative
way that can help give you words cause whenever
you talk…
I live in the bay area, whenever I talk about
this I just sound like a hippie.
It’s nice to have things that you can point
to to say hey look this is actual physical
systems here.
There something here that cuts common across
human experience that we can have a vocabulary
to talk about.
I think to that point too it’s important
to ask why we’re having this conversation
now and I think part of that, if I can flipped
that script a little bit, is we’re generating
all this data that’s being collected that’s
very, very difficult to wrap our brains around.
And these mental models help us understand
the sort of complexity and the scale of our
own behavior as a collective world and I think
that’s another goal, potentially of continuing
to research these new areas of cognition.
So let me ask you to take one more trip to
the table there.
You gave us a demonstration before of some
of the elemental, the basic gestures that
this machine, this system is capable of.
What if you tried to do something more complex?
So I think what I had here to show was sort
of more on the concept of creating tools that
actual musicians can use to explore.
Like we had that novelty sound of the cat/flute
for example, and so what I’ve done here
on my computer is to create a… we want to
get this into the hands of artist and musician
and to close the feedback loop cause creativity
takes two to tango, there’s the tool and
the person and so we want to get that feedback
loop closed.
So we created this plug in for this popular
software called Ableton Live that if you’ve
ever gone to see any electronic music, most
likely it was made for Ableton Live.
So here what we can do that instead of just
interpolating between just two instruments
we can create an entire grid of instruments
and allow a musician to take sort of a random
walk, take a walk through this space and explore
a whole variety of sounds.
So what I can do is rather than just play
this with my hand I can just sort of play
a clip here.
So right now the instrument is like an organ
sound and you can see this is the software
that we have going but you see we’ve created
a manifold for people to play on where we
can actually just drag through this space.
And see the evolution of sound as it goes
between different instruments and some of
the spots...
all of a sudden we’re in a dubstep thing.
But you can see the spots where it’s in
between the different sounds.
And it creates a whole bunch of different
textures…
alright that might be the start to my next
track, or something like that.
It gives you ability to interact in this space
that if you were trying to design by hand
to be able to draw through those things it’d
be very difficult to do.
Sort of one of those things.
Sougwen, where do you see computational creativity
headed in the visual arts?
Are there sort of analogous tools available
to you?
Yea definitely there a lot of style transfers
and this sort of visual assist…
style transfer is sort of the neural networks
reading the visual pixel data essentially
of an image, a popular painting for instance
and then extracting that style, like Starry
Night or what have you, and then transferring
that into your next selfie or a picture of
your dog or something.
Yeah, it’s compelling.
So I think there’s that as a very common
approach to using these systems in the visual
arts now.
What I get really excited about is ways in
which we can create new forms of collaboration
through sort of processes that we’re training
these neural nets on.
What about the visual arts as performative
arts where normally we only see the sausage.
We don’t see the grinding and all that but
it seems like with what you’re doing you
want us to see some of the process.
Very much so.
I think for me the creative process is much
more important than the outcome and that’s
why drawing as a collaboration, that’s why
it is drawing and not dance.
I think music performances is a little more
ambiguous, but actually being able to explore
the drawn mark in a way that isn’t representational
could be a reflection of consciousness or
sort of exploratory intentionality and doing
that alongside a, I hesitate to say artificial
intelligence, but machine learning system
approaches an understanding or at least could
create a data set that could help us approach
an understanding of what the exploratory creative
process is.
Well Jesse you know music throughout history
really has had a kind of ambivalent reaction
to new technologies, “oh my gosh digital
music.
All the musicians will be put out of work.
Oh my gosh the pianos.
Al the harpsichordist will be put out of work.”
And yet we still have real musicians, we still
have harpsichordists even.
So the idea that there’s room for a whole
new kind of generation of creative artist
in this field, it’s kind of a new idea,
but it seems like it has analogies to things
that have gone before.
Right in some ways it’s a very old idea.
That’s where I was sort of going that this
is kind of just part of a long coevolution
that’s existed between technology and music
in this case.
I think it really just takes a generation
that really owns it.
They don’t feel attached partially to the
things that came before, because they weren’t
alive when that was really happening so why
should they feel attached to it?
Some are traditional, I play jazz but I also
like pushing it in new directions.
So I think that will always happen, there
will always be people find strength in the
continuity of learning that harpsichord from
the 1600’s and those types of things.
Alright you mentioned the word ownership and
it gets up to something I said before I want
to come back to, that is agency.
So Lav you help create and your team helps
to create this entity that comes up with new
fashion ideas, new food recipes, new metal
alloys.
Who owns that?
So the current understanding of US trademark
and copyright patent laws that it goes into
the public domain because there has to be
a human inventor to claim ownership.
Machines don’t have property rights, at
least currently.
And so that’s the difficulty, it creates
this perverse incentive for people to pretend
like they were very fundamentally involved
in the creative process.
But it also raises the national question,
how should we think about property rights
in this area?
And it’s actually important because who
will fund the computational creative research
if you can’t actually patent using those
tools eventually?
So there’s no backwards flow of incentive
essentially.
So the nice thing let’s say pencils is they’re
considered researchable.
So it’s not the inventor of the pencil that
gets property rights on things that are invented
using pencils.
But when you do invent using a pencil you
can claim property rights on that.
Right so similarly we need some incentives
perhaps, a revision of this understanding
to encourage development of new computational
creativity technologies.
Peter?
I also think we need wisdom in handling tools.
Any tool can be a two-edged sword, a hammer
could be used to murder somebody or build
a house, even an atom bomb can deflect an
asteroid.
But these tools are so powerful that they
can kind of take on a life of their own and
that I think is a danger.
And I think there’s an example of that in
everyone’s pocket, right.
These cell phones are amazing.
You have all the information available in
the universe with Wikipedia right there.
But it becomes very distracting and many people…
I was walking across the Dartmouth green and
the sky was on fire with the red sunset and
everybody, a hundred people were doing this.
And I almost wanted to say people look at
this, but I didn’t have the courage to do
it.
I noted that in my mind thirty years ago,
walking across that Dartmouth green, I would
see ten people holding hands and I don’t
see that hardly anymore.
And these devices meant to foster human connectivity
have in many ways undermined it because people
are more distracted, less attentive, here
instead of talking to people.
Like when I was a kid and AI is very powerful,
but it runs the same risk, we have to own
it.
We have to become agentic ourselves and make
sure it serves our ends creative or other
wise and that we don’t become slaves to
it.
But if AI does reach a point Jesse, Sougwen,
where it can compose a piece of music, create
a genuine work of visual art, something that
moves us that genuinely passes the Turing
test, that we know where it came from and
it uplifts us anyway.
You don’t care.
Then does that AI entity have some sort of
agency, does it have some sort of ownership
as opposed to the humans who set it in motion
maybe a generation earlier?
(pause) We’re in William Gibson territory…science
fiction
I mean…
it’s all good stuff.
I think what you were saying about cell phones
and stuff, it’s really fun to think about
these scenarios where you start thinking about
personification and then constant evolution
and stuff.
But the fact of the matter is for technology
to ever reach that point, we’ll have gone
through so many transformative things in our
society…
like there’s lower hanging fruit than that
that will change everything.
And so I always think, like there’s lots
of groups like Google, open AI, DeepMind that
are really focused on more of the short term
things of like how does this affect our society
here and now and if we ever reach that point,
the only way we’ll ever do that if we figure
out all the stuff that came before it because
otherwise it just won’t happen.
But can I add that in order to get to that
point, we’ll have to have deep mental models
on what it means to be human being rooted
in what we have experience as being a human
being.
So for example you know that scene in Les
Mis where Jean Valjean is in prison for nineteen
years and he hates the system and he’s angry
and he stays with this priest.
He then steals the silverware of the priest,
and the police catch him and bring him in.
And the priest in a act of true Christian
grace says to him release him, he didn’t
steal it.
I gave it to him and here you forgot the platter.
And we find that deeply moving and beautiful
because we can understand having hit bottom.
And then by having hit bottom he goes through
a mental transformation and he realizes I’m
not this, I need to become a new kind of person.
That can only be understood by us because
we have human experience and I’m skeptical
that AI is going to be able to understand
redemption like that.
But maybe then again if we get to that point
they will be humans or very close to us.
Sougwen… tough act to follow there.
No, I think part of how we even categorize
what makes us human is how we create our own
narratives.
Like you explained this sort of profoundly
human moment through the narrative of Les
Mis.
I think right now we’re in the process of
creating narratives around machine learning,
we’re calling it artificial intelligence,
we’re calling it designed intelligence.
This is definitely an interesting precursor
to that question of agency.
We form our own through creating narratives
and now we’re able to co-create narratives
with these machines.
So I think that’s sort of the path forward.
The arc of human history has been to acknowledge
agency for more and more people.
Agency was for many generations was restricted
to a certain gender and certain group of people
and we hope that’s a continually expanding
definition of agency and whether it can include
things that are artificial.
I guess that’s a question that will be answered
down the road.